geehrte bürger russlands
das thema meines heutigen
auftritts sind die ereignisse in der
ukraine und auch warum es so wichtig für
uns für russland ist
natürlich meine ansprache richtet sich
auch für unsere landsleute in der
ukraine
wir ich muss um ständig und ausführlich
sprechen das ist eine sehr ernsthafte
frage die situation im don bassist
wieder sehr kritisch und ab und heute
wende ich mich an sie direkt damit nicht
nur die bewertung der ereignisse zu
geben sondern auch um sie zu informieren
um die möglichen möglichen zukünftigen
schritte und die entscheidungen die
getroffen werden zu informieren
ich betone noch einmal dass ukraine für
uns nicht ist kein einfaches nachbarland
das ist ein unentbehrlicher teil unserer
eigenen geschichte kultur und geistige
raums das sind unsere freunde unsere
verwandte nicht nur kollegen frühere
dienste
kollegen und auch verwandte die mit uns
eng verbunden sind durch familien
verbindungen das seit langer zeit die
einwohner der altrussischen
ländern nannten sich
russisch und orthodox so war es im 17
jahrhundert als ein teil dieser der
rhetorischen sich mit russischen staat
vereinigte und auch später uns scheint
dass wir eigentlich alles darüber wissen
dass im grunde es sich dabei um
allgemein bekannte tatsachen handelt
aber dennoch um zu verstehen was heute
eigentlich geschieht und die motive der
handlungen russlands unter ziele die wir
vor uns stellen zu verstehen müssen wir
ein paar worte über die geschichte der
frage erzählen ich beginne damit dass
das die moderne ukraine ganz und gar und
völlig von russland geschaffen wurde
beziehungsweise vom buddhistischen vom
kommunistischen russland diese prozess
begann praktisch sofort nach der
revolution 1917 und dabei linien und
seine genossen haben das ziemlich grob
gemacht in bezug auf russland selbst die
haben das
abtrennung und eines teil während
eigenen historischen territorien haben
sie das gedacht millionen menschen die
dort wohnhaft waren keine hat diese
menschen nach etwas gefragt dann am
vorabend nach dem zweiten tag nach dem
großen vaterländischen krieg hat stalin
udssr
angeschlossen und sogar jene übergeben
ein teil der länder die früher polen
rumänien und ungarn gehört und als eine
kompensation hat er in polen wird ein
teil der echten deutschen territorien
beschenkt und dann cruise hat irgendwie
die krim russland abgenommen und das der
ukraine auch geschenkt so entstand das
territorium der sowjetischen ukraine
aber jetzt möchte ich besonders auf die
anfangs seite entstehende und als dass
er ihre aufmerksamkeit lenken ich glaube
für uns ist es von großer wichtigkeit
wir müssen sozusagen von vorne anfangen
ich möchte in erinnerung rufen nachdem
oktober umsturzes und 17 und nachdem
nach dem bürgerkrieg begannen die büsche
wickeln die neue staatlichkeit
aufzubauen und es entstanden ziemlich
scharfe auseinandersetzungen stalin der
1922 den posten des generalsekretärs des
zk der
kommunistischen partei und des
volkskomitees vier nationalitäten hat
vorgeschlagen das land nach dem prinzip
der autonomie sierung aufzubauen das
heißt die republiken haben breite
vollmachten erhalten als sie dem
einheitlichen staat sich angeschlossen
haben linien hat diesen plan kritisiert
und hat vorgeschlagen den nationalisten
nachlässe zu machen er nannte die
unabhängige und diese linien idee der
konspirativen staatlichen unter das mode
dazu
das recht der nation zur
selbstbestimmung bis hin zur abtrennung
da die waren im grundlage des
sowjetischen landeskunde dann wurde die
integration der gründung der udssr
wurden diese prinzipien gefestigt und
nach dem tod lenins auch in der
verfassung der udssr 1924
hier entstehen sofort viele fragen und
die erste frage davon natürlich die
wichtigste frage wozu musste man
sozusagen von von einem herren die
nationalistische kommission am rande der
ehemalige des ehemaligen imperiums zu
gewähren und dabei wurden willkürlich
gebildete administrative gebilden unter
die uns die und große toren wurden
diesen gebieten übergeben warum sollte
man das über geben zusammen mit der
bevölkerung das ist doch schon russlands
an die weiterzugeben im grunde dieser
administrative einheiten bekamen status
und die form der staatlichen nationalen
gebilden ich frage mich wieder wozu
sollte man solche großzügigen geschenke
machen von denen sie die ganz scharfen
der journalisten frühjahr noch nicht
einmal geträumt haben und außerdem auch
diese blicken das recht zu gewähren dass
sie sich abtrennen hören dürfen aus
diesem stadt dass es doch ein wahnsinn
man versteht das auf den ersten blick
versteht man sich aber nur auf den
ersten blick es gibt eine erklärung nach
der revolution die wichtigste aufgabe
der bolschewiken bestand darin um jeden
preis an der macht zu bleiben und um das
zu erreichen waren sie vor allem bereit
auch die niedrigen den bedingungen des
priester frieden in der zeit als kaiser
deutschland in einer schwierigen
militärischen und wirtschaftslagen sich
befanden und der ausgang des ersten
weltkrieges eigentlich vorbestimmt war
und die erfüllung jeder forderungen
seitens der nationalisten wurden
innerhalb des landes so zusagen erfüllt
aus sicht der schicksale russlands und
erwiesen sich nicht nur als fehler das
war noch schlimmer als ein fehler nach
dem zerfall der udssr
wurde das ein absolut offensichtlich
natürlich die ereignisse der
vergangenheit kann man nicht mehr
verändert aber wir müssen zu mindestens
direkt und ehrlich darüber sprechen ohne
verschiedene auswege und ohne politische
vergehen ich kann von mir aus nur
hinzufügen dass die überlegungen der
laufenden politischen konjunktur
unabhängig davon wie effektvoll und
gewinnen sie zu der damaligen zeit
ausgesehen haben dürfen unter keinen
umständen als grundlage der basis
prinzipien des staates sein ich
verurteile keinen und werfer keinem
etwas vor die situation im land zu der
damaligen zeit nach dem bürgerkrieg und
davor war äußerst kompliziert und
kritisch heute kann ich nur sagen dass
alles ebenso gewesen war das ist eine
historische tatsache und wie ich gesagt
habe im zuge der bolschewistischen
politik entstand auch die sowjetische
ukraine die man auch so unser zeit ganz
und gar nennen kann ukraine die den
namen von leitlinien
trägt er ist sein ihr auto und architekt
das lässt sich durch archivdokumente
ganz und gar bestätigen einschließlich
scharfe linie direktive über den bass
die den bass wurde richtig ihn bestand
der ukraine ein gedrängt und jetzt die
dankbaren nachkommen haben die denkmäler
für linien abgetragen das nennt sich
dort die deppen kommuni sierung wollen
sie die ent kommuni sierung na bitte das
passt uns sehr gut aber man soll nicht
auf dem halben wege stehen bleiben wir
sind bereit ihnen zu zeigen was bedeutet
für die ukraine eine echte der
kolonisierung ich komme jetzt die
geschichte der frage zurück ich
wiederhole
1922 in den raum des ehemaligen
russischen imperiums wurde die udssr
gebildet aber das leben zeigt dass
sofort das ist sehr kompliziert wieder
so ein großes territorium zu erhalten
und noch das zu verwalten nach diesen
prinzipien war unmöglich das war die
waren abgerissen sowohl von der
wirklichkeit und auch von der
historischen tradition natürlich der
horte terror und stelle übergang zur
stalin diktatur herrschaft der
kommunistischen diktatur monopol der
partei aufmacht nationalisierung von
planungssystem in wirklichkeit
verwandelt es dass alles in eine
deklaration und formalität das waren
prinzipien dies war erklärt aber nicht
gegriffen haben keine souveräne rechte
hatte in der realität die sogenannten
unions republiken nicht es gab keine
solche recht in der praxis wurde eine
streng zentralisiertes unité rastatt
unter stalin hat war im praxis nicht die
linie sondern die eigenen eigene ideen
der staatlichen einrichtung aber
entsprechende
veränderungen in die system bildende
dokumente in die verfassung des landes
hat er nicht eingebracht die von denen
erklärten prinzipien des aufbaus oder
sie wurden nicht überprüft formell
maschinen es bestand ja eigentlich auch
keine notwendigkeit darin unter der
bedingung des totalitären system
funktionierte alles angst und es sah es
sehr gut aus anziehen und sogar sehr
demokratisch aber dennoch schade sehr
schade dass aus der basis grundlagen
formal juristischen grundlagen auf denen
die ganze stadt gebaut wurde nicht
rechtzeitig utopische berüchtigte von
der revolution eingegebene und für jedes
normales land zerstörerische fantasieren
entfernt wurden und von der zukunft wie
das früher bei uns war keiner dachte die
führer der kommunistischen parteien sie
waren wohl sicher dass sie ein sicheres
system der verwaltung begründet haben
dass sie durch ihre politik auch gleich
die nationale frage gelöst haben aber
die fas die verzierung verkauf von
begriffe und manipulierung mit dem
öffentlichen bewusstsein kostet sehr
viel da ziellos der nationalistischen
ambitionen ist nicht verschwunden und
die den statischen dem unität gegen den
nationalismus springt das war von anfang
an und diese mine war das recht zum
austritt aus der udssr in der mitte der
achtziger jahre im zuge der steigenden
sozial ökonomischen probleme und eine
offensichtliche krise der planung
wirtschaft durch die nationale frage
deren grundlage war nicht nur nicht erst
wäsche nicht erfüllten hoffnung sondern
die ansteigende appetite der lokalen
eliten stiegen aber die leitung der
körper des anstelle die situation zu
analysieren und adäquate maßnahmen in
erster linie in der wirtschaft zu lassen
und eine stadt staatliche system
beschränkte sich durch offenes wort
wortgebilde über die wiederherstellung
des klinischen prinzip der
selbstbestimmung mehr noch während des
kampfes innerhalb der partei selbst
jeder der kämpfende partei hat
kopflos nationalistischen stimmungen
gefördert man spielte darauf man
versprach den potenziellen anhängern
alles was unerwünschten und das eine auf
der grundlage der populistischen
geschwafel über die demokratie und eine
zukunft die entweder auf der
marktwirtschaftliche und der planung
aber unter bedingungen der totalen
verelendung der bevölkerung und der das
defizit dachte keiner der macht haben an
die unvermeidlichen tragischen folgen
für den für das land und dann geht man
weiterhin den gleichen vertrauten weg
zur befriedigung der ambitionen von
eliten die in den nationalen gemeinden
gegründet wurden und die in der hand der
kapitän so gibt es keine werkzeuge mehr
und macht zu erhalten und auch und und
man kann auch nicht mehr die diktatur
der stalinschen typisch weiter führen
und auch die diktatur dass der partei
verschwand buchstäblich vor deren augen
und so im september 1989 auf dem plenum
der kpd ist so wurde ein
verhängnisvolles dokument verabschiedet
nationale politik der partei werden
unter den bedingungen plattform der
körper des u und sie empfiehlt folgende
richtung die unions republiken gehören
alle rechte die deren status der
souveräne sozialistischen staaten
gehören noch ein buch und die höchsten
organe der machtorgane der unions
republiken dürfen bestreiten und
einstellen die verfügungen der unions
der union in ihren eigenen gebieten und
letztendlich jede uni unsere probleme
hat ihre eigene staatsbürgerschaft die
sich auf alle bürger dieser republik
verbreiten war es etwas nicht
offensichtlich wohin solche
formulierungen und entscheidungen führen
werden es ist nicht die zeit diese
staatsrechtliche oder
verfassungsrechtliche fragen zu lesen
und irgendwelche definition für
staatsbürgerschaft zu geben aber dann
steht die frage wozu unter diesen auch
sonst komplizierten bedingungen noch
weiter denn statt sozusagen auseinander
schaukeln aber dieser sache noch zwei
jahre vor dem zerfall der oder sehr war
das schicksal der oder vorbestimmt jetzt
radikalen und nationalisten
einschließlich schon in erster linie in
der ukraine schreiben sich selbst die
verdienste der
der unabhängigkeit so war das nicht zum
zerfall unser stand führten die
strategischen fehler der bolschewiken
unter führung der capitals zur
verschiedener zeit in der nationalen und
wirtschaftlichen politik gemacht wurden
zerfall des historischen russlands unter
dem titel der usa ist auf deren gewissen
trotz all diese ungerechtigkeit löwen
und offensichtlicher raub russlands
unser volk eben gerade das volk hat die
neuen geopolitischen realität anerkannt
wurden die neuen unabhängige staaten
anerkannt und nicht nur anerkannt
russland selbst befand sich damals in
der schwierigsten lage half ihren helfen
in der us einschließlich den
ukrainischen kollegen von den sie red
nach der erklärung der unabhängigkeit
viele viele anfragen über die materielle
unterstützung und unser start leistete
solche unterstützung unter achtung der
souveränität der
nach expertenberechnungen die man
einfach nach berechnung von
energieträgern und nach dem
umfang von toxischen krediten dieser
ukraine zur verfügung gestellt wird und
gesamte vorteile für die ukraine vor
zwischen 91 und 2013 betrug etwa 250
milliarden dollar aber auch das ist
nicht keinesfalls alles am ende 1991
schuldverschreibungen vor dass es eher
und fordern international und betrugen
etwa 100 milliarden dollar und zuerst
mal geht man davon aus dass diese
kredite von allen republiken der
ehemaligen oder sehr solidarisch
proportional deren ökonomischen
potenzial zurückgezahlt werden russland
hat die tilgung des gesamten schulden
der so wird hängen übernommen und hat
das ganz und gar bis alt endgültig wurde
dieser prozess im jahre 2017
abgeschlossen
stattdessen sollten die neuen
unabhängigen staaten zum teil sich
verzichten auf ein teil der
ausländischen aktiver und entsprechend
der vereinbarung wurde
1994 auch mit der ukraine erreicht aber
hat diese vereinbarung nicht ratifiziert
und später weigerte sich überhaupt zu
erfüllen und hat die ansprüche gestellt
geben wollt vorräte und andere vermögen
und aber dennoch
trotzte die
bekannten probleme hat russland immer
mit der ukraine ehrlich
zusammengearbeitet mit respekt vor der
interessen wir hatten verbindungen in
allen möglichen bereichen so 2011
unserer bilateralen handels und
überstieg 50 milliarden dollar ich muss
sagen dass
2009 10 noch von der pandemie lag dieser
handelsaustausch mit allen anderen
staaten unter dieser summe und die
ukrainischen machthaber haben immer so
gehandelt dass sie in bezug zu russland
alle rechte und vorzüge genossen aber
keine verpflichtungen anstelle der der
partnerschaft haben sie schmarotzertum
vorgezogen und das war also
rücksichtslosen charakter seitens der
macht haben wir erinnern uns nur auf
diebstahl von gas und andere ich füge
hinzu dass hier hat man versucht diesen
dialog mit russland als vorwand zum
handel mit dem westen und haben
erpresste und
bei moskau verschiedene präferenzen auf
diese weise sozusagen sie sich gewonnen
und ukrainische macht haben ich möchte
dass begonnen vom ersten schritt haben
sie ihre staatlichkeit gebaut auf der
weigerung von allem was uns vereinigte
die versuchte historisches gedächtnis
und bewusstsein entstellen viele
generationen von menschen die in der
ukraine wollen dass es kein wunder dass
die ukrainische gesellschaft mit einem
akuten nationalisten und konfrontierte
und das hatte also aggressiven
nationalismus und rassismus
deshalb die die die beteiligung der
ukrainische nationalisten an den banden
im nordkaukasus es schlangen immer mehr
die ansprüche und forderungen an
russland die eigene rolle spielte auch
die
außendienste die die haben in russland
ihre klientel aufgebaut und die einzige
macht gebracht man muss verstehen dass
die ukraine niemals eine eine ständige
tradition der eigene staatlichkeit
gehabt und seit 91 lief sie auf dem wege
der mechanischen kopieren der fremden
modelle die sowohl von der geschichte
als auch von ukrainischen realitäten
weit entfernt sind politische und
staatliche
instituten wurden schnell um geändert
und angepasst an clans an deren
eigennutzen interessen die nichts
gemeinsam haben mit den interessen des
volkes rahmen der ganze sinn der
pro-westlichen wale zivilisations wahl
bestand und besteht nicht darin um
bessere bedingungen für western des
volkes zu schaffen sondern darin um
sich die dienste zu leisten an die und
und viele milliarden dollar zu bewahren
und die sozusagen in westlichen konten
zu verstecken die einen finanzgruppen
industrie finanzgruppen die von anfang
an stürzten sich auf die nationalisten
und radikalen die anderen die
lippenbekenntnisse waren gute
beziehungen mit russland und sprachliche
vielfalt und kamen an sie macht mit
hilfe der bürger die aufrichtig diese
bestrebungen unterstützen einschließlich
auch vier millionen von einwohnern im
osten der ukraine aber nachdem sie
posten bekommen haben und ämter da haben
sie ihre wähler sofort verraten und ihre
versprechungen fallen lassen und die
reale politik wurde für unter dem
einfluss der radikalen geführt und
verfolgten die früheren die diejenigen
die die unterstützt haben die für
zusammenarbeit mit russland aufgetreten
haben die haben benutzt dass die
gesetzestreue bürger die gewöhnt sind
die den machthabern zu vertrauen und
diejenigen die niemals aggressiv und
sind und niemals
widerrechtlicher aktion sich da haben
die radikalen immer frecher die
ansprüche der radikale stiegen und es
fiel denen nicht einfach deren willen
der schwachen machthabern aufzudrängen
und diese macht war selbst von
korruption und journalismus erfasst und
die waren kulturellen wirtschaftlichen
sozialen interessen des volkes wurden
durch und reale souveränität der ukraine
durch verschiedene spekulationen auf
national boden und äußere attribute es
stadt keine sichere staatlichkeit in der
ukraine und jeweils verfahren gelten nur
als als schirmen zur aufteilung zwischen
verschiedenen oligarchischen planen die
korruption die natürlich ist eine
herausforderung und problem für viele
staaten ist einschließlich auch russland
gewann in der ukraine ein besonderen
charakter das versetzte regelrechten
ukrainische stadt alle zweige der macht
alle systeme die radikale nutzen metzler
die gerechte und zufriedene der menschen
und stellten sich an die spitze des
protestes und
2014 führten sie mal dann zum staats und
stieß dabei bekommen sie direkte
unterstützung seitens der ausländischen
staaten die materielle unterstützung
dieses protestlagers auf dem platz der
unabhängigen seit der botschaft der usa
betrug eine million dollar pro tag
zusätzlich
große summen ganz frech wurden direkt
auf die banken konnten der
oppositionsführern überwiesen und das
ging um dutzende von millionen dollar
und wie viel geld bekamen die
tatsächlich menschen die
deren familien gefallen sind und deren
angehörige gefallen sind darüber fragen
wir nicht die radikale haben die macht
ergriffen und haben eine verfolgung und
terror gegenüber denjenigen
veranstaltet die gegen verfassungs
maßnahmen führten gegen politiker
journalisten wurden misshandelt wurden
öffentlich für erniedrigt in den
ukrainischen städten gab es viele morde
straflose wurde und gewalttaten man kann
nicht ohne ärzte dann an die
schreckliche tragödie in odessa denken
als die teilnehmer der friedlichen
protestaktion wurden lebendig verbrannt
im gewerkschaftshaus
die verbrecher die dieses verbrechen
verübt haben wurden nicht bestraft und
keine sucht nach 10 uhr aber wir kennen
deren namen und wir werden alles tun
damit es sie bestraft werden
dass wir sie gefunden werden und die vor
gericht gestellt werden mai dann hat die
ukraine der demokratie und fortschritt
nicht näher gebracht nachdem staatlichen
umsturz nationalisten und die
politischen kräfte die sie unterstützt
dann haben die situation endgültig in
die sackgasse gebracht ukraine wurde in
den abgrund des bürgerkrieges gebracht
nach acht jahre nach diesen ereignissen
ist der stadt zerrissen der berliner
erlebt eine akute wirtschaftskrise nach
der information der internationalen
organisationen
2009 10 fast sechs millionen ukrainer
ich betone das sind etwa 15 prozent
nicht
arbeitsfähigen bevölkerung sondern der
gesamten bevölkerung mussten das land
verlassen auf der suche nach arbeit und
dabei häufig auch in der lage wurden sie
zu
tagelöhner und qualifizierte arbeit
bezeichnet ist auch die andere tatsache
seit 2020 unter bedingungen der pandemie
haben das land etwa 60.000 ärzte und
pflegekräfte verlassen im dezember des
letzten da haben wir anti-westliche
laden ein vertrag zwischen der
russischen föderation und den usa über
die garantie der sicherheit übergeben
und auch über die garantie der
sicherheit der russischen föderation und
den staaten genau starten aber in der
antwort gab es viel gemein einfach
allgemeine worte und es gab auch
rationale kern aber das betraf alles
sozusagen neben fragen ist ja alles als
ob man die diskussion irgendwie in die
seite führen wollte wir reagierten
darauf wir sagten wir sind bereit die
verhandlungen zu führen aber wir haben
gesagt da alle fragenkomplex betrachtet
werden im paket ohne abtrennung von den
wichtigsten russischen vorschlägen und
sie enthalten drei wichtigster posten
das ist nicht zulassung keine weiteren
nato expansion zweiter
verzicht auf die stationierung von
angriffswaffen systemen das müssen an
den russischen grenzen und letztendlich
militärische potenzial und infrastruktur
des blocks auf den stand von 1997
zurückzuführen als russland nato grund
akte unterzeichnet wurde eben gerade
diese wichtigsten vorschläge wurden
ignoriert die westlichen partner
wiederhole ich haben nochmals
nochmals bereits so
bereits wiederholten formulierung dass
jeder staat das recht hat die eigene
sicherheit zu wählen und jeder allianz
und jede bündnis jedem bündnis
beizutreten das heißt in deren position
hat sich nichts verändert man man hört
die gleichen hinweise auf die politik
der offenen türen mehr noch man versucht
uns wieder zustand addieren zu erpressen
mann bedroht uns mit sanktionen ich
glaube dieser aktion werden sie so oder
so einführen wie wände die souveränität
russlands steigen wird und die stärke
unserer streitkräfte und der vorwand für
den nächsten session angriff wird immer
gefunden oder vielleicht einfach
fabriziert und zwar unabhängig von der
situation in der ukraine das ist nur ein
ziel die entwicklung russlands zu
bremsen und sie werden das tun so wie
sie das auch früher getan haben
auch ohne jeglichen formen formellen
vorwand nur weil wir existieren und weil
wir niemals auf unsere souveränität
unserer nationalen interessen
auf die verzichten werden ich möchte
direkt sagen und unter diesen umständen
als unsere vorschläge über
gleichberechtigten dialog und
grundsätzliche fragen ohne antwort
seitens usa nato geblieben ist und als
das niveau der bedrohung für unser staat
hat der russland das recht recht die
antwort maßnahmen zu üben zur sicherung
der eigenen sicherheit und genauso
werden wir verfahren was die lage in den
wassern geht wir sehen dass sie führende
der marktführer in kiew erklärt vielfach
über nicht bereitschaft minsker
vereinbarung erfüllung sie sind nicht
interessiert an der friedliche lösung im
gegenteil wir versuchen wieder in den
bus ein blitzkrieg zu organisieren wir
das bereits 2014 und 2004 15 war wie
damals diese affären zu ende gingen
können wir uns erinnern kein tag vergeht
zurzeit ohne beschluss der nur der
siedlungen es wurde eine einer gruppe
von militärischer volle benutzt ständig
drohnen raketen artillerie und salben
feuer die die misshandlungen der
menschen zwischen kindern und
älteren menschen hören nicht auf wie man
bei uns es gibt überhaupt kein ende
dieser sache und so genannte
zivilisierte welt
die einzigen vertreter dieser welt
erklärt man sich unser westlichen
kollegen die ziehen vor das nicht zu
merken als ob es nicht diesen albtraum
nicht vorhanden als ob diese voll traum
nicht vorhanden diese genozid dem 6 4
millionen menschen unter waffen nur weil
diese menschen nicht bereit waren ja zu
sagen zum umsturz in der ukraine
2014 und uns die waren gegen die
bewegung des staates in richtung kauf
nationalismus einen höhlenartigen
aggressiven nationalismus und weil diese
menschen für das reicht in ihrem land zu
leben in ihrer sprache zu sprechen in
ihrer kultur zu leben und tradition wie
lange kann so etwas noch andauern wie
lange kann man das noch dulden russland
hat alles getan für die erhaltung der
territorialen integrität
der wir haben kämpften für die erfüllung
der
resolution der uno
2022 wo die wo die minsker frieden
festgeschrieben wird zur regelung der
situation im sonntag alles vergeblich
die präsidentin wechseln die
abgeordneten des parlaments aber
verändert sich nicht das wesen der
nationalistische aggressive charakter
des regimes dass die mächtigen tief
ergriffen hat das ist also alles die
frucht des staatsstreichs
2014 und die und die damals auf den weg
der gewalt blutvergießen gesetzlosigkeit
die erkennt keine andere anerkennung der
frage und was außer der militärischen
lösung in diesem zusammenhang halte ich
für notwendig eine längst reif gewordene
entscheidung zu treffen
unverzüglich die souveränität und
unabhängigkeit der volksrepublik tornetz
und der volksrepublik no ganz
anzuerkennen ich bitte der versammlung
diese entscheidung zu
ratifizieren und die verträge über
freundschaft und gegenseitige hilfe zu
ratifizieren
diese beiden dokumente werden in der
nächsten zeit auch unterschrieben und
von denen die die macht in kiew alten
verlangen wir sofort die kampfhandlungen
einzustellen andernfalls die ganze
verantwortung für mögliche fortsetzung
des
blutvergießens wird ganz sogar auf dem
gewissen der führung auf dem territorium
der ukraine in dem ich diese
entscheidung erklären bin ich sicher
dass die bürger der russlands mich
unterstützen alle patriotischen kräfte
russlands nicht unterstützen